يبدو ان اسره اللعب البرتغالي كريستيانو
رونالدو تاقلموا بشكل سريع في السعوديه
وهذا الشيء شفناه في ستوريه شريك جورجينا
اللي مو بس جالسه تشارك مع الناس انشطتها
وجولاتها في السعوديه لكن امس كمان طلعت
لنا او طلعت لنا في ستورياتها بناتها هي
وكريستيانو والانانا وايفا وهم بيغنوا
بالعربي ويبدو انك كانت بتستعين بجوجل
علشان تفهم ايش بيقولوا وتصلح لهم كمان
خلينا نشوف المقطع
الثلاثاء الاربعاء الخميس الجمعه
[موسيقى]
السبت الثلاثاء الاربعاء الخميس الجمعه
احب
[موسيقى]
ان شاء الله يعني مخارج الحروف مزبوطه
الصاء والخاء والجيم يعني كثير ناس تفاعلت
مع المقطع وعلقت على الموضوع هذا كمان
نذكره بالشبه بين اللغه البرتغاليه
والعربيه في مخارج كثير احرف واللي يبدو
مسهل على بنات رونالدو العربي